ich habe es wie so oft so ein geburtstag
gewünscht ich habe es nie bekommen und
jetzt ist es einfach in so einem
überraschungspaket drin hab die ganze
angst dass ich das ding recht irgendwo
hinkriege wo es wehtut
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht's gut machen mache ich
eben erst das zweite mal so ja ja so und
zwar heute mal wieder ein video auf das
nicht persönlich auch sehr vorher
einfach weil ich gespannt bin ich habe
damals irgendwann mal so ein amazon
überraschungspaket bestellt genau hier
vor acht monaten und dann habe ich an
die zwei sogar genau und noch mal vor
sieben monaten und da gab es ja auch
echt viele videos zur leute sondern
überraschungspaket von amazon ausgepackt
haben und ich habe in letzter zeit sehr
oft was zu der seite wish gemacht ich
bin irgendwie abends ganz spontan auf
die idee gekommen auf wunsch zu gucken
ob es auch so was gibt und ich habe
etwas gefunden es war zwar sehr schwer
weil da gibt es allen möglichen schall
das ganze ist auch erstaunlich
angekommen also ich hab es ungefähr vor
fünf oder sechs tagen gestellt und es
ist schon da also viel schneller als ich
das sonst gewohnt war ja so sieht das
ganze aus eigentlich wie ein übliches
paket ich könnte jetzt auch gar nicht
sagen wo das genommen hat kommt aber es
ist ganz gut eingefügt das ganze hat
glaube ich 23 euro gekostet versand war
irgendwie nochmal sieben euro von ich
bin mal gespannt was drin ist es ist
jetzt kein ich habe hier mal 1 bestellt
für 100 euro bei amazon das war
natürlich deutlich größer ich bin
gespannt was drin ist ich habe aber auch
einfach mal auch noch anderen seiten
geguckt wo ich in letzter zeit noch was
bestellt habe zum beispiel auf juden
oder auf aliexpress oder so und da gibt
es auch noch überraschungs boxen könnte
man hier vielleicht mal überlegen das
auch noch zu machen einfach weil
vielleicht noch mal andere sachen drin
sind oder ob die gleichen sachen oder
ähnliche sachen keine ahnung
das kann man ja nicht sagen also wenn
ihr darauf bock habt zum beispiel mal
auf jugend last man doch nach oben da
dann sehe ich das ja auf jeden fall und
dann gibt es das kommende woche auch
noch mal wenn sie schnellstmöglich an
kommen trotzdem würde ich sagen wir
laden jetzt gar nicht lange und ich mach
das mal aus
[Musik]
zehn jahre später
ok also wenn man reinschaut
es ist jetzt ich muss sagen nicht mega
viel drinnen ich würde sagen das sind so
12 sachen vielleicht die tatsachen sind
auch noch mal extra eingepackt und ich
würde sagen ich fange einfach mal an
wir haben als erstes strohhalme 100
stück logisch vielen dank dafür wollte
ich immer schon mal haben strohhalme
damit ich auch wenn ich mir ein getränk
machen kann das vernünftig dringen kann
mit dem stroh ein in gelb ist meine
lieblingsfarbe ich muss jetzt mal gucken
mich würde mal interessieren ob sich das
wirklich oder ob man diese strohhalme
auch wirklich jetzt auf ruhig kaufen
kann strohhalmen ja und hier gibt es
wirklich eine menge strohhalmen also
leute wenn ihr auch schon immer mal
stroh helme haben wollte
kauft euch ruhe was ist eigentlich ein
strohhalm zwei strohhalme schreibt mal
in die kommentare was die mehrzahl von
strohhalmen so wir machen weiter und
haben hier kopfhörer oder doch was ist
das denn leute unfassbar geniale
kopfhörer mit einem stern drauf also die
ersten beiden sachen waren ist auf jeden
fall brauchbar ich das jetzt mal kurz
wie die qualität davon ist irgendwie
verstehe ich grad überhaupt nicht wie
ich die hinter meine ohren kriegen soll
also so ok ich hab' sieht auf jeden fall
echt stylisch aus jetzt muss ich das
ganze weil doch hier kurz verbinden ums
iphone zu kriegen
[Musik]
also ich hätte jetzt wirklich schlechter
erwartet aber es ist okay natürlich das
ist wirklich schlecht und es ich weiß
nicht dass raus so ein bisschen also
schön anzuhören ist es nicht aber was
will man auch erwarten ich gehe mal
davon aus die haben höchstens zwei euro
gekostet da gucke ich jetzt auch ob ich
die finde ich hab mal kopfhörer gesucht
aber irgendwie sucht er noch gut die
kopfhörer finde ich jetzt gerade nicht
auf die schnelle aber hier gibt es auch
eine menge mit irgendwas das eingepackte
h ich hab's mir so ein geburtstag
gewünscht ich habe es nie bekommen und
jetzt ist es einfach in so einem
überraschungspaket drin eine einhorn cap
ich glaube ich habe sie gerade kaputt
gemacht an die habe ich dann aber doch
heute schreibt man die kommentare steht
die mir ich finde schon kann man auch
perfekt andersrum aufsetzen oder auch
nicht die ist echt klein also ich glaube
die ist eher etwas für jüngere es gibt
auf jeden fall sehr viele einhorn nützen
die speziell wahrheit doch die schnauze
draußen was ist denn da los
[Musik]
alex und video auf irgendein typ kommt
auf die idee draußen sauber zu machen ja
danke für die netten so wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten und zwar heute
wir haben hier ein flummi der leuchten
kann so sieht das aus gefällt mir
wirklich mathematik achtet man drauf
[Musik]
nein
oh mein gott heute bin ich jetzt dumm
oder habe ich wirklich mit dem flummi
hinten guck mal bei mir ist gleichzeitig
das mal kurz hier wird gehen einfach die
rollladen rauf und runter und ich glaube
ich habe
mit dem flummi getroffen einmal kurz die
wiederholung wird ob der flug irgendwo
dahinten gegen gefetzt ist also das ist
bis jetzt auf jeden fall das geilste was
man sich eben schon gesehen
macht euch mal kurz die rouladen wieder
auf ich habe mir eben schon gesagt was
ist das bitte für ein zufall
einfach weil wir so ähnliche schwämme
japan zum spülen werde allerdings kein
wir haben keine spülmaschine und ich
konnte gestern nicht spüren weil ich
keine schwemme hatte und jetzt habe ich
einfach welche finde ich wirklich
richtig gut genau auf mich
individualisiert das paket geil wirklich
sonnenbrille
ich glaube ich hatte schon mal so eine
ähnliche gründe hey warte mal ich glaube
irgendwann aber zum paket war auch so
was drinnen kann das sein
ich kann mich gerade nicht mehr ganz
genau daran erinnern aber es sieht
wahrscheinlich gerade total scheiße aus
dadurch kann man nicht mal wirklich
sehen wenn man die länge auf hat wird er
echt schlecht aber sieht natürlich
lustig aus ja danke für diese
wunderschöne brille
als nächstes haben wir ein bouncing ball
weiter so sieht das ganze aus ich weiß
nicht was das genau kann aber ich habe
mit vermutung man schnallt sich das hier
einfach mal um das handgelenk
haben sie angst dass ich das ding recht
wohin kriege wo es wehtut
also ich muss wirklich sagen ich hätte
es schlechter eingestuft es sind
wirklich sachen mit denen man spaß haben
kann
vor allem die der baum symbol oder ein
flummi das macht richtig spaß
bis jetzt nein das erstmal wieder ab und
haben jetzt gilt als nächstes moment das
hier hat es läuft auch schon mal und
zwar haben wir so eine pistole
wo man diese teile drauf tut das gab es
früher glaube ich selbst auf der kirmes
und wie genau funktioniert das ich bin
ich jetzt gerade dumm oder funktioniert
das echt so ua ja danke das kann man
sofort in müll klopfen so als nicht ich
habe ich einfach noch ein hot wheels
vielen dank für dieses wunderschöne auto
fast sogar wie mein eigenes kann ich
aber auf jeden fall verschenken vor
allem so hot wheels ich glaube so einer
der kostet bestimmt drei euro oder so
gut vielleicht ist es irgendwas
gefälscht ist aber eigentlich geht es
nicht so aus und eine sache aber noch
und zwar ist das knete also das einzige
was jetzt wirklich cool war der baum
symbol und der flummi der flummi ist
mein highlight einfach weil der es
geschafft hat die rolle wie hoch zu
machen
die kirche kann springen ja ich noch
nicht glaube
das war nein wir haben noch jenny beans
leute jelly beans das sind diese boden
also wir können lecker schmecken oder
nicht liegt also wenn ich das ganze
rechnen dann haben sich die 20 euro auf
jeden fall gelohnt das war das
überraschungspaket von roche ich hoffe
es hat euch einigermaßen artikel hat
sogar mit form gut mit so knete kann ich
nicht viel anfangen
trotzdem war es eigentlich ein cooles
paket hat spaß gemacht man aufmachen wie
gesagt für einen jugend paket oder so da
können auch gerne in die kommentare
schreiben ob ihr noch irgendwas anderes
kennt lassen dann nach oben da dann sehe
ich dass das eher darauf bock gehabt und
wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich morgen
wieder genau morgen kommt um 14 uhr oder
am 15 und richtig cooles video habe ich
eine wundervolle idee ich war früher im
tanzkurs und habe wirklich so ein paar
sachen kann ich auch also dieses jahr
aber schön dass du auch deine juli hat
ja das ist schon mal gemacht ja
natürlich habe ich ja quasi als 28 und
eine sache fehlt noch nicht irgendwas
ist noch drin in dieser box was ist das
nur deutsche alter es ist einfach mein
merge der am 28 04 rauskommt so sieht
das ganze aus muss da hinten drauf
musste an den seiten muss da vorne
schreibt durch das hinter die ohren 28
vierter am samstag kommen dieser merger
auch das war natürlich auch noch in der
überraschungsbox und ja ich hab das
wieder durchgefallen ist dann mal oben
da wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich dann
morgen wieder check instagram ist ab und
hat rein